according to the LA Times the number of
Californians aged 50 to 64 who live in
their parents homes has surged in recent
years people 50 to 64 moving back in
everyone thought it was just the
Millennials moving back in with mom and
dad no it's people in middle to upper
middle age we've got some more info for
you for seven years through 2012 the
number of Californians aged 50 to 64 who
live in their parents homes swelled to
67% to about a hundred ninety-four
thousand that seems insane among 18 to
24 year olds 1.6 million Californians
have moved in with their parents though
that's a 33 percent jump from 2006 the
pace is still half that of the 50 to 64
age group there's so much here now none
of us are in that age group yet is this
really an economic thing do you think
that that really is what's going on here
that these people just start falling on
hard economic times it seems weird for
that age group doesn't it yeah it does
but I feel like well first of all I hope
this means that we can stop raiding
millennial trend pieces if it's not just
the Millennials like let's read some
trend pieces about 50 to 64 year olds
that was one of the first things are
loading off their parents yeah wasn't
that nice wasn't it nice when you saw
this because it was like oh they're not
just I don't know how you and old
millennial do yes
you're a millennia so we sent it
refreshing you see some other age group
be besmirched
I hate boomers it's sad it's sad because
like you know obviously the economic
issues at play and it's more stigmatized
to move back home when you are 50 than
when you are 20 but yeah I also it is it
is kind of like one of those things
where we look for kind of trends like
these lazy Millennials and I feel like
these issues kind of are the economy at
large not just like a group of aged with
people being you know lazy not working
right so we have a bad economy all
together people just attack the
Millennials because they're the ones
getting in the workforce in a bad
economy not the one because we're so
obnoxious that it's like we're an easy
target and the sad things with you
people should we be judging these you
know look in Europe you know
in your look at Italy almost everyone
lives with their mother in it yeah
it's should we be more like Italy I
think I think we should be more like
Italy mother let me stand food yeah no
it's I think it's sad more than anything
and I think it's a statement on the
economy in a huge way but I think it's
also a statement on the type of jobs
that are available and a lot of people
in this age group are trained for jobs
that no longer exist and aren't properly
trained for the jobs that are starting
to exist and the 50 is not you know
that's middle-aged and there's not a a
great way to train a ton of middle-aged
people to learn the you know you want to
you want to do job training and you want
to give people a chance to get educated
enough to get back into the workforce
but it moves so quickly that by the time
you know somebody who's trained in
computers in the 90s is already if they
haven't been staying up with that is
already totally behind right now yeah so
it's not just a bad economy but then
they're not trained properly for the for
the jobs that exist right now do we put
too much of a premium on getting out of
the house like even this reminds me of
like every episode of The Cosby Show
right cliff was always trying to get
those kids out well we do we do though
culturally you know you're right though
in Europe it's not the same and many
other countries it's not the same I mean
the US has a weird thing about kids go
into college and never coming back which
is not realistic in this economy so I
think that yeah it's a weird cultural
thing I don't know if other cultures are
so into people who have been out of the
house for 30 years then coming back
right but yeah I mean it just seemed
like a weird thing that we've had have
been conditioned to believe that you
have to kind of get out immediately and
never look back
yeah well it also makes sense though
that what started this terrible economy
was although it started to rebound but
what started the economy was the housing
crisis and so a lot of the people in the
50 to 64 Adrian probably owned houses
that were foreclosed upon and so they
were probably former homeowners who are
now renters who can't afford their rent
anymore like it's the natural conclusion
of people who were foreclosed on eight
years ago yeah you know I mean there's
definitely a litany of reasons that it's
going to isn't there something nice
actually about people this age moving
back in you know you have elderly
parents that are probably in their 80s
or 90s at this point and you know people
do it's usually thought of the other way
that the elderly parent moves in with
the child or they kick them off to Shady
Pines I told I was gonna get one Golden
Girls represent I appreciate so but
isn't there something nice about this
that we should actually respect more you
know like in Japan where they really
have a respect for the elderly that we
sort of don't have here what do bummed
me out about the LA Times piece the
woman in the piece says that it was
because of her twins that she moved back
in if they had not been around she would
have lived in her car so I was like it's
her mom reading this because my mom read
that I'd rather live in my car than with
my mom I think she'd be a little upset
yeah well we'll link to the article in
the description by the way so you can
find out about a bit more about her yeah
it's just depressing it's so sad and it
is nice to be with family and to be but
nobody wants to come back hat in hand
and also nobody wants to be written up
in the LA Times about how they came back
hat and look you're already embarrassing
enough but to go to be like yeah so then
my life really fell apart and now I have
to live with my parents my kids like
that sucks like not everybody read about